o lado pessoal aqui quem fala é o lugar
que seja muito bem-vindo chamar de neve
e os traços de quebec dia só há um lance
como vocês já puderam ver nós temos aqui
com os nossos irmãos e óculos país mas
não são 11 jogos bastante bons
isso é rio e da virtual do hoje em dia
quando vocês não vencer estes jogos
passam a ver é isso é o futuro seria um
mau tempo não só os temos aqui com jogos
gripe porque nós vamos jogar uma não
estava em jogo vai ser uma experiência
ou seja votar dentro dos jogos ricos
dentro da floresta dentro dos
dinossauros não estava entre o deus né
os dinossauros chuva por ser a minha
volta em coisas vão acontecer
ela simplesmente sexual por isso para lá
e para os nossos jogos em 32 ou dois
quando estalar os dedos do corta e
depois os jogos e parecem próximas
janeiro e foi campeã acredito nos meus
vídeos 321 o meu deus estamos no não
isto não é tão jovem presta embarque
dentro então linda em 32 o único não não
está muito real meu a sério trás do
prédio vai escrever em die está muito
bom parece que estou aqui dentro mesmo
não acontece nada meu olha só esse ovo é
melhor não sabiam que era bebê
eu e isso é melhor do que o meu o
movimento não é pois aí eu fui embora da
costa amiguinho a ai ai que isto eu
saiba vila parece mesmo que o fmi meu
sai do morro ainda está aqui sai né nem
só sabe chutar a gol não sai daqui né
haia holanda aquelas roupinhas merda né
a senhora tá aí no leste do metrô
o pessoal está curial meu
aparentemente eu tô dentro de um ninho
de dinossauro é bom acho que estou a fim
de nos ao lado do astro já não sair mas
as coisas vão acontecer é que a ai ai ai
espaço estou a fugir quando o espaço de
fogem da floresta é porque foi um macaco
maior da floresta ai não perder acho que
a noção mesmo aquela estátua real e
estudava à noite que terá outra morte
pra mim nenê
eu não vou pra mim aí ouviu ficar quieto
da arquitectura icarly um filme ou outro
olhar perante o olhar mais do que pra
mim 34 eu sou né
ae nem onde não sou fruto é muito ruim
tudo isso ninho de nos auro até então
não pára de olhar pra mim porque porque
como um raio bairro judeu eu já disse
que o frio do brasil a oi o odacir
embora o meu deus eu fico muito a
desculpa amigo e eu sei que vou buscar
eu sei que tu voltas cargas por enquanto
pode contrair embora passear com o teu
amiguinho ayoví encheu o estádio cheio
de lá para a moody's também integrada
que traz para então o partido ak jato
cais da praia está tudo escuro porque
não é isso que com este vídeo eu sei
como vai ser porque não sei que essa
experiência foi pequena mas ultimamente
o youtube não deixem guiar vídeos não
consegui conquistar os filhos como
deveria para fazer né eu já tinha dito
que optaram por dia e não consegui fazer
o que não conseguiu fazer upload e é por
isso que eu estou te servir os mais
pequenos porque é mais fácil enviar e
tal mas mas é isso pessoal espero que
tenha mesmo estado já sabe quanto vai
falar em favoritos quiserem ver assim
mas fica só com os filhos comem tem
jogos que vocês saibam que vamos estar
ou o que for passar mal assim ninguém
nos comentários
é isso ai q favorito fique bem até a
próxima